napa et son petit qu'alors les câlins ça
fait du bien et la télé aime les câlins
alors pour votre bien voici une petite
sélection d' étreintes
on commence avec une archive de 1983 de
l'émission merci bernard dans ce
programme
chaque semaine les présentateurs offrir
aux téléspectateurs un cadeau un peu
drôle et ce jour là
jocelyne nous offrait un câlin accrochez
vous ça y est vous êtes bien collé
contre la vitre de votre téléviseur ok
on va faire un bon câlins c'était bon
hein pour ça c'est pas grave
un petit chiffon humide et merci
jocelyne allons voir jacqueline
maintenant jacqueline vite en normandie
et en 1988 ce n'est pas un sketch elle
explique qu'elle communique avec les
arbres eux
il lui parle et elle elle les serre dans
ses bras
voyez toute la ligne des chakras tout le
corps qui parle du faux
un vus jusqu'à l'os du bas du corps
comme ça et après je me sens un certain
moment et après je me sens bien
rechargées il ya une communion qui se
fait avec la toujours dans le mystique
connaissez-vous amas de son nom complet
mata amritanandamayi c'est une grue
indienne adulé des stars invitées aux
nations unies par le pape françois aussi
est partout où elle passe
elle attire les foules sans pouvoir
donner des étreintes d'un amour infini
démonstration en 2006 à toulon tout
comme c'est naturel pour la rivière de
couler c'est naturel pour moi de donner
la main
quand je vois les gens souffrir je le
ressens et je suis leurs larmes sur mon
épouse pour les consommables grande
prêtresse ou pas le cas l'un est bon
pour la santé
c'est céline rivière qui nous
l'expliquent une étreinte libère de
l'ocytocine et l'ocytocine est une
hormone qui est extraordinaire puisque
ça permet de libérer beaucoup de
bien-être de la confiance en soi et
c'est exactement à l'opposé des hormones
du stress vous savez ce qu'il vous reste
à faire
un bon gros câlin et pourquoi pas des
inconnus dans la rue avec un gros
panneau free hugs câlins gratuits comme
ces opérations organisées depuis une
quinzaine d'années
[Musique]